wanted to play this one oh no oh very
exciting corny
jim cornett look for those who don't
know we're wrestling fans
and uh jim cornette does a wrestling
show called nwa power and it's been
getting good buzz it's been getting a
good buzz because it's kind of a
throwback to old wrestling shows it sure
is
well jim cornett's in trouble for saying
something
something that not many people liked
mike so let's just that's 14 seconds
let's play it
and let's see in these 14 seconds if we
could spot the thing that he said
that was bad this is seriously is he
is he might trevor murdoch he's mad
bad and dangerous to know he's the only
man i've ever known that could strap a
bucket of fried chicken on his back and
ride a motor scooter across ethiopia
trevor murdoch can take
so uh
kind of a bit of an archaic
joke now somebody provided a clip uh two
of him saying that
uh in a match years and years ago
between bob backlund and some jobber
oh [ __ ] in wwe it's back in the day
though yeah
so this is like an old it's from corny's
mental joke book
right right right uh maybe something
that he could have retired
knowing the current climate but he uh he
has uh resigned
he's resigned from nwa since this clip
ad
it was a whole thing dude last night
people were losing
their [ __ ] minds and he was trending
like coronet was trending worldwide
number seven not for the reason he
wanted though huh nwa
and cornett was trending and i was like
that can't be good
and i even know i got to give a shout
out to say and z i'm going to give a
shout out to kyle from saying z because
he was doing a stream and he was talking
about cornet
and i was like wait what happened with
cornett i'm like looking into it i'm
like oh no
yeah he had to resign people are people
want to hear it again actually
this is seriously is he is he might just
trevor murdoch he's mad bad and
dangerous to know he's the only man i've
ever known that could strap a bucket of
fried chicken on his back and ride a
motor scooter across ethiopia trevor
murdoch
it's funny he should have updated it at
least yeah a little bit right
yeah it's funny uh
i certainly am not a big fan of people
you know cancel culture
obviously no no i don't look i think we
agree
i think it doesn't bother me or anything
but i think sometimes when we talk about
this stuff
there's a difference between what we
think and what
dude you know what's gonna happen yeah
and and he's
so this is so
close to just a few months ago with
n-word gate
yeah there's that tape of him and when i
say he says the n-word on tape
i'm telling you he loves saying the
n-word in this tape
like to the point where you're like oh
boy and he kind of got away with that
one
so this to me i'm like i i love courtney
and i don't think
obviously i'm against cancel culture but
he probably should have been
choosing his words a little more
carefully like he dodged a bullet with
that n-word tape
yeah he i i i think updating would have
been better like he would have
he he's the only guy i know that could
have taken a
bag full of popeyes chicken sandwiches
and walk them through opalaca
like that's more updated that's more
like modern or literally people were
saying to like
literally any other food country combo
yeah i think was different like uh uh
drive with a truckload of tequila
through mexico city and survive
that that that could do but the truck
then trucks protect he's just strapped
it to him that's gotta strap
and it has to be some sort of i guess
for the joke to work in jim cornett's
mind
there needs to be some sort of feral
blacks
that are starving and are ripping your
flesh from your body to get the chicken
it could have been any other food he
could have said he could have strapped a
stack of pizzas to his back and rode
through ethiopia
you know what i mean and people go oh i
get it it's a starving joke but he
literally was like
it's ethiopian french and again i don't
support anybody getting cancelled
especially for that but you just got you
skated past that n-word thing
he he's been he's been the cause
here's the thing wrestling fans are
starting to get woke too and it's very
gay
oh it's super gross um so there are all
these like millennials coming up like
um you know that's phobic and in our
space
we're not gonna have that kind of attack
like that guy dabbing aladdin
champ smokes oh the one that was hitting
on the 15 year old
what which guy was was it oh king
aladdin remember the one sitting left it
also had an aladdin name remember that
wasn't
a 15 year old that we covered it the guy
that the dad walked up to him
no oh no no no not yet but that was also
in aladdin i'm not wrong with that
okay it was something allowed no i was
thinking there's this guy dabbing
aladdin
oh the aw guy the guy oh yeah yeah w for
making fun someone tell me who it is
people and stuff because they
look we're not gonna have transphobic
language in here and he was tweeting
about it and he's banned from all aew
events
they're starting to get kind of got this
stuff so i'm just saying
i'm against canceled culture but corny
should
know from his twitter dealings lately
that they have been watching him like a
hawk like they want a piece of content
for a while
woke wrestling twitter what's going on
taking down he shouldn't on that
that that's that's that's another very
good point and something else someone's
pointing out is
it's it's even weirder because cornet i
follow him on twitter
is a vocal lefty oh yeah he hates you
trump's a racist trump's racist all
right we don't have a [ __ ]
three-minute tape of trump saying the
n-word
500 times in a conversation you know
that's a very good
next one i was like get that n-word out
of here get mad
mar-a-lago's not for n-words you'd be
crucifying you right of course
so corny does have a bit more of a i
don't know
spicy past and he is known for
like there are wrestlers that say like
yeah dude he's a [ __ ]
he's he was a racist he uh he didn't he
didn't pay people
he repeat you know what i mean he's
treated a lot of people like [ __ ] so you
have to know like
you either you either can make fried
chicken and n-word jokes
and keep be the most beloved person in
the world or
you can be a complete shit-heel and
watch
everything you say and do right and
that's you get you can't both you can't
just be
reckless as [ __ ] and also be hateable
because eventually people gonna start
looking for everything you do
for some reason people are playing
blaming vince vince russo
i don't know how but i agree anything
when it comes to wrestling when it's
failed you have to blame vince russo
like i'm pretty sure if you
if they rolled tape backstage at wwf
back in the early 90s there's probably
some clips of him saying it
dude remember when vince said it what's
up my remember that one
that's that's a classic that is a what's
up one
that is a cl and that's the owner of the
wwe
and remember yeah crime time like i'm
just saying primetime wasn't that long
ago
yeah it's very shameful in wrestling and
jim cornett making a [ __ ]
bucket of fried chicken joke is not the
worst most egregious
uh instance of racism